Good afternoon.
Hope everyone's reinvent is going, uh,
going as well as ours.
Uh, I'm very excited to spend the next 19
minutes, uh, with all of you.
So, uh, my name is Jared Summers. I'm the
CTO at, at LMI.
For those that, uh, don't know LMI, we're
a next-generation
solutions and products provider. To the federal government.
And so over the next few moments I'm going to talk to you
about what really makes LMI
special and what enables us to
move
incredibly quickly for our customers, blending
COT's solutions with the federal
security requirements.
So we're ready on day one for the mission.
And so, so I think, you know, the,
the exciting thing is the administration
and the change that has been occurring
in the federal space over the last,
you know, 12 to 18 months. There's been a strong
demand for CT solutions. And
why? And that's because
the federal government has realized
that there's a ton of technology
available out in the market
that if they could get it securely and in the
right format,
they could leverage the investment,
the broader investment outside of
the federal space to provide the capabilities
to their customers, their individuals
even faster.
And so what they want to do is to leverage
the innovation and the investment made
in the commercial space
on the on the federal side. And so
when you think about COs, it's really
easy to move fast and to innovate
when you don't have a lot of
the security requirements that we have on the federal
side. So for those that operate
in the federal market space, there's a ton of acronyms
whether it's CMM.
FedRAM,
ATO,
NIST, and etc. and the list goes on.
And so how do you bridge and
merge the speed and the innovation
while still delivering securely? And that's what we're gonna
talk about for, for the next few minutes.
And so, first, a little bit about LMI.
So LMI has actually been around for 65
years, so we're not a tech native
new company.
However, over the last 3 years. We've changed
really the focus on our delivery
to leverage the business model we're going to talk about here.
So we've pivoted away from
services to solutions and
products driven by our IP
and the investments that we've made over the last 3
years of hundreds of millions of dollars
to buy companies and integrate them in a secure way,
so we show up on day one with mission
ready tech that our customers can use
out in the field.
So, so how do you actually bring
and merge the innovation and
everything that the customers want with
the security requirements that our customers
have? And so I've got 3 examples that I'm
gonna walk through here pretty quickly.
So the first
is
A lot of problems and challenges have been
solved in the commercial side for decades.
When we think about
IoT enablement, when we think about
tracking inventory, when we think about understanding
where are our assets, where are things in
transit, I think
across those three use cases we're
all thinking of companies that do this incredibly well.
This technology is not new.
Amazon does this incredibly well in their warehouses.
However, there's still the security side
when you think of federal customers, particularly
in the DOD,
DHS, and a lot of the other mission units
where they don't
really want that data exposed everywhere.
So, so what do you do?
So this morning we announced
Specter, which is our commercial
solution that actually solves this problem.
And what we've done is we've
acquired the commercial tech and
we've hardened it
within our reusable platforms and we'll talk
about in a moment that we show up on day one
with all of the infrastructure,
the hardware, the data transport,
and the analytics that are all secured
by design ready on day one so
we can deploy to our customers immediately and
they start to see the value
on day one.
And so that's, it's really exciting.
The second is adapt and deploy
in a creative environment. So
it's very difficult to show up to a
government customer
when it's pure straight cop. So if you
don't understand the rules of the game, back
to the acronym SOUP that we talked about a few
moments ago,
and you don't know the baseline that you're building
for, it's incredibly hard for your
solutions to to get into the target
environments.
So what we've done internally through
extensive. R&D
funding is we've built
and accredited our own platform
that is to FedRAM P and
to IL 5 standards, so
everything that we build internally,
all of our solutions, all of our capabilities
from day one
are built to the security baselines that
our customers need.
And so what that really means is when
we align on a solution that we
have
that our customer needs, when we
show up on game day, on day one,
the containers and the applications that
we bring
pass through all of their security
checks with a clean bill of health so
that we can deploy quickly.
So we can either bring our own environment that
we have accredited or we can deploy in
their target environment.
And so our internal environment is called iron sled.
And so we use that to, to build all
of our internal capabilities. A great example,
um,
there was a, a customer that we saw
a, a use case that was, that was
not being met.
We took that information back internally
and started to, to build uh
an application to solve that particular
problem.
Leveraging all of our secure harden
containers and our pipelines and our
co-depositories,
we were able to turn
an MVP, which is actual functioning
application containerized,
and show it to the customer in 72 hours,
get their feedback,
because what we all know is customers
really don't know what they want until they
experience it,
until they can actually interact with something that's
real and be like this solves my problem,
or actually know I needed to do this.
And so we could take that 72
hour turn,
get that customer feedback,
make the improvements and the changes, and
then show up a week later with even a
more robust application.
And so we were able to, to go from
idea
to. First concept in 72 hours
to come back
fully incorporating their first
round of feedback
in weeks. And now that is, is live in a
customer environment being used for exercises
actually this week uh as uh as
we're here, which is incredibly exciting.
The, the next is
extract core components for, for reusability
and repeatability.
And so, on the commercial side,
they're really good about not recreating
the wheel every time.
And so what that really means is
when you're building
your applications, when you're building your capability,
built with modularity and reusability
in mind. So a great example,
uh, for, for us is uh a platform
called Raptor.
So Raptor has been in use for
over a decade by starting with the Space
Force to solve really hard modeling and simulation
challenges,
but the way that it was architected was
a toolkit of different solutions
and capabilities
that we could put together in a modular
way to solve a variety of different customer
challenges.
And so that means it can not only
solve
very bespoke,
incredibly challenging
space-based comms network
solutions, but it can also be used
to optimize for asset
availability across a very diverse
landscape like Indopeca, for example.
It can be used to solve very
challenging problems around medical logistics
and the like,
because each of the components themselves
are reusable and modular,
that we can bring the right components to
solve the problem,
iterate with the customer in near real time,
and be able to provide that solution
that they can use.
And so
the, the investments that that that
we've made and the strategy that we've taken.
Has enabled us to take all of the
great things that the government wants
to leverage
from, from a cop's perspective
and marry that with the
requirements that are just necessary that are part of doing
the business within the federal government.
And so to be great partners
and what they were really looking for is
they're looking for companies that have demonstrated
the behaviors
of co-investing.
So when you think about the capabilities
that we use in our daily lives,
we did not like applications on our phone,
for example,
we did not
pay for a company to build
that application,
and then we wait 1824
months, 3 to 5 years.
But unfortunately,
historically, that is how software
delivery and capability has been in the federal government.
And it's just not the right answer.
The right answer is demonstrating
the right.
The right partnership attributes,
co-investing
and showing up on day one with
capabilities that they can use
that are modular, that are reusable, but
at the same time are built to the
to the incredibly important
security
standards that that that you need to deploy
in the environments given
sometimes the risks that are associated with emissions in which
the technology will be used
and so.
You know, when you think about that,
really, that's, that's cots done right.
And when you do that right,
you build a tremendous amount of trust
with your customers,
where when you show up and you're demonstrating
those right behaviors, and when you show
up and you can actually deploy your capability,
and you, and your, and your tools
pass their security scans cleanly,
it builds a tremendous amount of trust
that enables,
you know, a,
a whole additional,
you know, conversation on, well, what else can you do?
Well, what else can you bring?
And this has worked really well for EMI.
It's over the last few years,
you know, taking this approach to our customers
has allowed us to grow
by 68% KAR.
I mean, that's incredible. For a 65
year old legacy company
who's been able to transform itself
into a solutions and products,
and to experience that type of, type of growth
is nothing short of amazing.
And that's because of the model that we're here
talking about today and what we've been able to do.
So, success really isn't, it's not
about skipping customization,
because,
you know, when you think about it,
What they want from Cots is
the speed and the capability,
but that doesn't mean it, it doesn't have to be customized,
and I think that gets lost in the
conversation. Because, you know, for
a lot of our customers and probably a lot of your customers
as well, there are some direct dual-use
applications, you know, when it comes to some of the back-end
process uh processes, you know, whether that's HR,
you know, processing everything else. But when you're talking about
mission-focused, mission-forward
applications, you know, whether that's for CBP,
whether that's for the Department of the Army, whether that's for Space
Force, whether it's for the Postal Service,
the challenges and the scale
at which they face
does require customization.
And so I think it's really important for all of
us
in the narrative in the conversation,
KOs does not mean that there isn't
customization to actually solve the use case,
but what KOs really means back
to behaviors is that we're showing
up on day one
with secure solutions and we're investing
ahead of need
to actually, you know, solve their problems.
And so it's really achieved by the balance
of the innovation and the speed.
But bringing, you know,
the investment and the behaviors and the security
necessary to deploy.
And so with that, actually.
It's kind of all I have to say. Does anybody have any
questions? Anyway.
Nobody. No questions?
I can keep talking if you want.
What's that?
Keep talking. All right.
Let's go back one then.
I'll give more examples.
Um.
Yeah, so I think, you know, let's go back to, to
Spector a little bit.
Uh, so that was the first one I talked about solving
intransit visibility, asset availability,
uh, and really, you know, solving the problem like
where are my things and, and how many things do I
have. And so the announcement
that we made this morning uh was
around, we went out and acquired um
IP surrounding this.
Uh, so now the entire tech
stack
from tags
to, to Edge compute
to transport
all the way up through the, to the Edge
data cloud Edge cloud,
Edge to cloud and enterprise is all integrated
in one solution.
And so when you think about also cots,
something that we're seeing from our customers
that you're probably seeing from yours as well, is
they're looking for those integrated solutions
that they can buy commercially
that solve the problem
at speed.
And so the investments that that we made and
announced this morning that we successfully
demonstrated
both at a very large use case for the army
and for the navy
enable us to move even faster.
And so back to being a good partner,
we have gone off and invested our own
money to de-risk that
delivery because now we control the entire
stack. So instead of relying
on other third-party providers, whether
it be for hardware or for
transport,
now they have one integrated solution
that is secure end to end.
And so that enables us to, to move with
speed, but then also to, to
come with the commercial business model.
So now they can buy as a service.
So that's something else that you're probably getting from your customers
is,
you know, I see on the commercial side, I can
buy as a service. And so what does that mean?
And so what that really means and what we've
found they're asking for, and I'd love to validate with all
of you is
instead of just buying a thing,
they want to buy outcomes and capabilities
based upon SLAs.
And that's exactly when you think about when you're
buying commercial tech to
support your, your own development, that's
exactly what you're buying. It's what are the SLAs
that I am paying for that you are
signing up to to deliver that capability. All
right, now we got a question.
Yeah, yep.
Yeah, yeah, so
the, so the, so the Navy project,
the Navy has a, has a, has an
opportunity to increase throughput at all of the naval
shipyards.
And so, you know, a big part of that is
they are incredibly large,
uh, you know, areas if you've
ever been. To a naval shipyard,
same use case. So I came from oil and gas. If
you've ever been on a refinery or a chemical plant, you
know, the exact same thing,
very disparate, very large,
but at the same time it's very
complex because as you're breaking down
a navy vessel,
there's all these pieces, parts, and components
that have to go off for repair
or for overhaul or that you're replacing.
But then,
where do they go?
How do you track them? And some of those
pieces and components
are incredibly important
because, you know, they deal with nuclear propulsion.
And so if, if you lose one of those,
and by lose I mean just misplace,
that shuts down the entire yard
until it's found.
So you could lose a day or two
of productivity from absolutely
everyone in the yard
looking for that piece part or component.
And so what our solution does
is it tracks and provides that asset
visibility
across the entire life cycle from the, from the
time it's taken off
all the way through the the repair,
the overhaul, the replacement, but then all the
way to the time it gets back
because now that data plugs in and goes
into all of their scheduling and planning,
because how often,
um, if you know anything about shipyards,
if you know about any manufacturing, how often
is something scheduled to be installed.
But you don't have the right part or they scheduled it out
of order, so you put a larger component
and left 2 or 3 things behind it.
Now you got to go rip something else out to
put it back in. And so not only do
you have, you know, time saving some efficiency
to, you know where everything is and so you're not, you
know, double, triple, quadruple ordering
things, you know where it is, you know when it's ready,
so then you're also scheduling the right
crews at the right time,
you know, to go, to go reinstall the parts
in the right order.
And so the, the entire
process there is about enabling the Navy
to, to turn ships at the
organic shipyards faster, more
efficient, at a lower cost.
And so that's what Spector is doing for the Navy,
um, and it's been, it's been incredibly
exciting. So I think, I think we talked about
more of that in the, the press release if you'd like to know
more LMIsolutions.com.
Uh, we talked about that and, uh, and the Army example
as well.
Uh, and that is solving the problem
when you think about army depots,
you know, they are, they're resource constraints. They
have a ton of assets.
So where are those assets,
um, and so we partnered with them to, to answer
that problem, you know,
where, where are the assets, what condition
are they, are they in, you know, what components
are, are, are on that, that larger asset.
So we have parent-child relationships,
um, you know, different capabilities and tags,
uh, for different specificity. Um,
and that, so that enables them for the exact
same use case. I need to go find
a transmission
for, you know, uh, an AMV,
you know, in this configuration,
exactly where is it
instead of driving around, you know, 230 acres
trying to find,
you know, the right vehicle at the right
time. And so that drives, you know, you know, that
efficiency.
Um,
did I do that? I didn't do that.
Anyway, great question. Thank you.
And so
really appreciate the opportunity to share
a little bit about LMI,
who we are.
I think the exciting journey that we've been
on for the last 3 years,
I think, you know, really shows
and should give, you know, excitement, encouragement.
Like this is possible.
You can do this,
um, and we're happy to talk
more about what we do and
how we do it.
We're over at booth 491,
which is straight down this hallway to
my right, your left,
uh, and we'll have people there all week that, you
know, we love talking about the capabilities
that we have.
We partner well with others.
Um,
we, we pride ourselves on actually being a good partner.
Uh, and so if that's something you're interested, please
stop by and talk to us.
Otherwise,
thanks for stopping by. I appreciate it.
Thanks for your time.